[Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  i say either  you say either i say neither can i say  neither  either neither neither let's  call the whole thing off  catch up excuse me  yummy  good evening eddie hey mrs chen good  evening venom  bergson  [Music]  you and i are the same  every decision we ever make  [Music]  who do we leave behind and how  do we leave them waiting  in the darkness of the rescuer who never  comes  welcome back eddie brock it's been a  long time  miss you so much  [Applause]  soon come chaos  chaos  the chocolate delivery hasn't arrived  yet no we had a deal  what's gonna happen you're gonna stop  protecting me i am happy to eat mrs chen  no  no you cannot eat mrs chen what nothing  [Music]  you